okay my first guess is the former
republican governor from ohio who
spoke on the first night of the
democratic national convention this week
and endorsed joe biden for
president our friend john kasich
governor
uh i know they say politics makes
strange bedfellows did you ever think in
your wildest dreams
that you would be at a democratic
convention opening for bernie sanders
well it seems a little bit uh you know
kind of
out of the ordinary bill but you know my
whole career i've
had great relations with people in the
other party one of them
uh is a guy named ron dellums you might
recall he was a very liberal
democrat he was a congressman he was the
mayor of oakland
and he and i became very very close and
you know i did things with
actually with ralph nader on corporate
welfare with tim penny on balancing the
budgets
so you know this is not uh even though
it's
i would have never kind of imagined this
it's not that i'm uncomfortable
seeing people in the other party as
somebody that i can work with and
and help in some ways but speaking at a
democratic convention obviously
uh is something out of the way that's a
lot bigger
obviously a lot bigger but yeah but i
got to tell you at the time with some of
the things i did with dellums which was
the limit to production of the b-2
bomber
i mean i was actually in a meeting with
republican leadership and a guy there
accused me of being a traitor
i mean those were big things i mean that
was that was big time when you start
taking on
major weapon systems and we limited the
production of it
but this is big time you know to be at
the convention
but and when they asked me to do it i
had searched my conscience as you would
expect and
and i i thought about it and i thought
this is the right thing to do
uh and i hope you kind of felt as though
it was a classy talk because i
you know i i tried to talk about what's
important in our country yeah it was got
good reviews and it should have
uh but i'm just saying this is endorsing
telling people to vote
for the person who is not in your party
let me ask you this
a little bit tougher question would you
have done it if you were still in office
because i see a lot of republicans doing
this
colin powell spoke there and a number of
other susan molinari
um meg whitman um
all retired uh and you don't see it a
lot from
republicans in office in fact you know
just another good question
only one question yeah but you can
remember you can remember that i
expanded medicaid right uh it was very
controversial at the time yeah
i was the only major republican governor
in the country that did that
and i was heading into uh to re-election
and i went ahead and and did it you know
because i thought it was the right thing
to do and not only did i
hide from it i went out and explained to
people why i was doing it
so you know bill life is so short you
know it's just so
short and when you feel really compelled
and it's a matter of conscience you got
to do what you have to do
and but i can't project back i can just
give you an example of what i did that
went against the grain and
and i'm comfortable with what i've done
and let me tell you this i get a lot of
heat for this too
i get praise and heat all at the same
time and i knew it would come
that's life yeah and now that you want
people to go out especially in ohio
which is close this year very close
you want people to go out and pull the
lever for the democrat do you have any
regrets
about some of the things you did maybe
when you were governor that
really served to suppress the votes
of democratic voters the use it or lose
it law which you push through which says
if you haven't voted in two elections in
a row they take you off the rolls
uh cutting down on early voting i mean
some of that stuff is
what democrats are always accusing
republicans of doing
which is the only saying the only way
you can win elections is
basically by cutting down the number of
people voting
well bill first of all we have we have
more early days of voting it's easier to
vote in ohio than about any other state
and secondly that whole e you know use
it or lose it was something i
i didn't pass that that was something
that was in effect but one of the things
that i did do was tell the legislature
that i was not going
to go along with the idea that people
had to have a driver's license id
because i felt that that would be that
would be very unfair and it would hurt
people
so uh i'm satisfied with with what i had
to do
and in terms of uh in terms of that uh
that
that
early voting again i think we have like
29 days of early voting
uh it's more than what they have in new
york so maybe people ought to catch up
to
us rather than we worrying about you
know how many days we have we've done a
good job here with that
okay well listen i'm going to read you
what
the president said yesterday
which uh i hate to keep being and i told
you so on this show but
donald trump said the only way we're
going to lose this election is if the
election is rigged
which is basically saying hence i win
tails you lose
and then they asked kelly mcinerney
about it and she said
yeah you know they're in the we'll see
what happens mode which is of course
not the answer you want to hear from a
president about will you accept the
results of the election donald trump
also said we're going to win four more
years and after that we'll go for
another four
because they spied on my campaign we
should get a redo of four years
i mean he's doing my act for me this guy
um
i still think people are not taking this
as seriously
as they should what do you say and what
should we do
yeah bill my concern is this so you have
a guy out here
already setting it up saying well you
know i think there's we're going to be
ripped off
unless i win and the problem with it the
deep problem with it
is if you get like 20 or 25
of the people in this country that don't
believe in the legitimacy of a
presidential election
you gotta you have a real real problem
and that's when i first
heard him talking about that's when
through what went through my mind
you can't have a situation where the the
president of of the united states and
just think about it there's precedence
for this you remember richard nixon felt
that things had not gone the right way
when he ran against kennedy he thought
he had grounds of protest he didn't do
it
al gore you know i know al very well al
you know al was able to concede he said
look for the good of the country
i'm not going to fight this so we have
republicans and democrats who have
have put the country first and what you
see with these comments to me
uh it is it's it's beyond deeply
troubling
because if you get that number of people
that don't believe in the legitimacy of
the election
where do we go from there so i just hope
it's going to be a sweeping victory but
i think even with a sweeping victory
you're still going to have people that
doubt the outcome but that's the mess
we're in and that's why i spoke at the
convention
right because the things like that
cannot be tolerated yeah i still don't
hear what we're actually going to do
and it's more than just i think people
who don't accept the election
it's that both sides use this word
existential
about if the other guy wins america is
over
when you have two camps like that
who think that it's the end of the
country the end of our life
as we know it if the other side wins no
in what world is joe biden the end of
america i don't know
but that's where they are do you really
think there's going to be a peaceful
transition of power
well bill i would i don't want to
speculate that things could go
it could go negative there i i don't
want to do i don't want to feed that
i don't have to be something you need to
talk about but i
i will tell you that that's another
reason why i spoke because
the the hatred through clinched teeth
doesn't now
exist just with politicians it's now
down in the families
it's in the it's it's with neighbors
it's with friends
uh i mean i have never seen a time and
and
it's been getting there getting it now
it's been fed you know it's like putting
gasoline on a fire
where you know it used to be the
politicians didn't like one another but
now when you have
families being broken people can't talk
about this
this is what really troubles me and it's
so ridiculous because we're americans
and right it's that everybody's they're
in their own silos it's tribal and i
wrote a book about this in fact we
talked about it before it's called it
it's up to us if you can't you you fix
everything from the bottom up not the
top
down and when the public is divided you
can't get anything done
and that i i it's i'm so upset about
that because i see it
every single day well listen i commend
you
for uh speaking at this convention and
endorsing biden i think that was a
really great thing you did
and for those people who are hostile to
you you say you're getting a lot of heat
you know i know that some sometimes
comes from the left and i just want to
say to those people
look this country you're always going to
be sharing it with some people
a lot of people who just don't see the
world the way you do
and you have to accept that it seems
like we're in this place where we want
to
own each other and obliterate each other
no one wants to
compromise and that's something that you
and joe biden have in common
you're two guys who no you know who
accept that people have differences
you can't own them you have to work with
them
we have to co-exist
you